Welcome to English in a Minute, where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
Have you ever heard this before?
I'm starving, let's grab a bite.
If someone has ever told you in English that they were going to grab a bite,...
...and you were confused, this is the right program for you.
All this talk about food is making me hungry.
Yeah, I'm starving too.
Do you wanna grab a bite?
Sounds good.
In American English, when you say you want to grab a bite,...
...it means that you want to eat right away, or that you're interested in eating quickly.
If you want to make plans or sit down and have a nice, fancy meal at a restaurant,...
...you may want to say something else instead.
And that's English in a Minute.